[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Let's do a thought experiment.
Everyone close your eyes.
Let's say when you walk out of here,
you see a shiny object in the bushes.
You bend down and
you find it's a magic lamp.
You rub it and a genie comes out.
And the genie says, hey,
I'm actually a genie in training so
I can only grant you one wish.
But here it is, if you tell me
the one thing you want to do in life
with no fear of failure,
I'll make sure you're successful.
It may not be a week from now,
a year from now, or a decade from now.
But once you tell me, success will follow.
Open your eyes.
What would you ask the genie for?
A year and a half ago, my fourth
week at Stamford Business School,
an instructor named Graham Weaver
challenged my class with this assignment.
Later that night,
I went home to think about it.
But after an hour, I was stumped.
I had no idea what to ask the genie for.
You see, I, like many of us, had grown
up learning how to think practically and
that meant going after the highest paying,
most prestigious jobs available.
The formula was, put in your dues first,
fulfillment second.
And until I came into business school,
I lived that.
In college, I studied to make As, and then
when I graduated I took a corporate job.
And put my head down.
Never stopping to think about
what I actually wanted.
You see, I was confusing busyness and
obligation with a sense of purpose.
So I was sitting there thinking about
the genie, I realized I needed to rewind,
to go back through all the things
that had excited me in the past.
It wasn't that corporate job, nor
was it any of my hobbies that I had
in college, cooking or architecture.
No, I had to go back even further,
all the way to high school.
As a kid, I loved stories.
I was pretty awkward.
So in lieu of real friends, I had the
characters from Mice and Men, Catch 22,
The Old Man and the Sea.
Stories were pure magic,
it transported me to a different world,
the time I felt most alive was when I was
reading, falling into living stories.
So I decided to act.
The next quarter,
that first week of January,
over a year ago, I walked into
an undergraduate creative writing course.
Now to be honest, I don't remember
the material we covered on that first day.
What I do remember is that for two hours
I didn't even think about my phone.
I was on a different planet,
not a different department.
When I left class, I was tingly, something
I haven't felt since high school.
For the last year,
I followed this feeling.
I've taken four more fiction courses.
And this winter, I submitted applications
for MFA programs in creative writing.
And I love it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I wake up at 5, 4, 3 in the morning,
just to squeeze in a few
extra hours of writing.
I read a short story everyday.
And I aim for a novel week.
I can't get enough.
But leaving in a secure world of business
for the unsure one of fiction writing.
Following my MBA with an MFA is risky.
And that is far away from
practical as you can get.
For me and for many of us, there's a
tremendous tension between the things that
put food on the table and
those that excite us.
This tension was studied
by famed psychologist,
Abraham Maslow,
who combined anecdotal evidence
with stories from successful individuals
to create the Hierarchy Of Needs.
Our primary needs,
Maslow said, are physiological.
That's food, water, sex.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Once
those are taken care of we seek safety,
that's shelter.
And only once if you're protected do we go
after first love, then self-esteem, and
finally at the very peak of
the pyramid self-actualization or
what we might call fulfillment.
Growing up, I subscribed to this model.
Over the past year, though,
I started thinking about it differently.
What if we change the formula?
What if, instead of fulfillment last,
we put fulfillment first, and
trust that the rest will follow?
Now, I fully understand that to even have
a conversation about self-actualization
is a luxury and a privilege.
But when we're more engaged in our careers
and in our lives, we're more effective.
We're better able to put food on
the table and roofs over our heads.
Leading with fulfillment isn't
ignoring those primary needs.
It's focusing on what's
really important so
that we can find fulfillment
while we meet those needs.
And actually our brains are wired for
this.
You see, on the outside,
we have the neocortex.
It's the part responsible for
rational thought, and
it helps us put our heads down and
work at any given task.
But beneath that is the limbic brain,
related to emotion and fulfillment.
And it's this part that actually
drives and motivates our behavior.
So how do we do this?
How do we start with fulfillment?
In my experience, there are two steps.
First, find that thing that lights you up,
second go after it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Right, so that sounds easy, but
obviously it's not.
So let's unpack it.
First, find the thing that lights you up.
This is the genie exercise,
what would you ask the genie for?
Sometime this week,
take just ten minutes to think about it.
Maybe it's that childhood passion
you've been ignoring for years or
perhaps it's that thing you find yourself
doing when you're procrastinating in
your studies or at work.
And step two, go after this thing.
Learn taekwondo,
start a fashion website for dogs,
or dedicate your life to this kind of
cash flow analysis, if that's your thing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Whatever it is, go after it.
And every week, continue to take those
ten minutes to check in with yourself.
Ask, is this thing still firing me up?
If it is, awesome.
Keep at it.
If it's not, and
you have to be honest with yourself here,
go back to step one, back to the genie.
And this, this is the hardest part.
This is the part nobody talks about.
If you're like me,
you won't find the thing on the first try.
It will be the 4th, or
the 5th, or the 15th.
When cooking was my thing,
I started filling out applications for
culinary school.
When it was architecture, I picked up a
civil engineering degree as an undergrad.
None of those pursuits are my thing,
they didn't fire me up.
So I gave up on culinary school and
let my engineering degree
gather dust on the shelf.
This is the part nobody talks about
because the act of trying, and failing,
and moving on, trying, and failing,
and moving on, is mucky, and
disheartening, and it's embarrassing.
When you try something and
it doesn't work out,
it's almost impossible to go back to
the genie and ask for yet another thing.
But we have to.
The punch line of the genie
exercise is that you are the genie.
You have the ability to
grant yourself this wish.
You have to trust that no
matter how many things you try,
no matter how low you get,
that when you go after this thing,
when you find your creative writing,
everything else will follow.
Decades ago, Abraham Maslow
described self actualization,
something achieved by the likes of
Thomas Jefferson, Abraham Lincoln,
Albert Einstein, as becoming fully human.
And one of the key characteristics of
these individuals was their ability to
have peak experiences, feelings of
ecstasy, harmony and deep meaning,
feeling at one with the universe,
stronger and calmer than ever.
Now I'm no Lincoln or Einstein but when
I write, I get a taste of this feeling.
And I'm up here today because
I want you to feel it too.
To become human, to be self-actualized,
to earn those feelings of ecstasy and
deep meaning.
And you don't have to win the Nobel prize
or totally change your career to do it.
Fulfillment is a life-long
investment banker,
starting a dairy farm in upstate New York.
It's a single mom who volunteers in
the soup kitchen every Thursday night.
It's part-time,
it's full-time, it's a week from now,
a year from now, a decade from now.
It's out there for you and for me.
Now, I don't have it all figured out.
If I can't hack it as a writer,
I'm going to have to get another
job that will pay the bills.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But for now,
I'm putting fulfillment first and
trusting that the rest will follow.
Almost.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What will you accomplish
when you find the thing
that lights you up?
What will you ask the genie for?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [MUSIC]